[Musique]
thélem maupin bonsoir merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors une
cérémonie de signature entre israël et
les émirats arabes unis a donc eu lieu
ce soir à washington en présence de
benyamin nétanyahou donald trump et il
apparaître comme un faiseur de paix à
cette semaine de la présidentielle
en tout cas il s'efforce t elle paraître
comme un faiseur de paix ils essayent de
restaurer sa réputation en tant que
faiseur de paix après les catastrophes
les désastres des quatre dernières
années il ya eu une dégradation des
relations entre les etats-unis et l'iran
entre les états unis et le venezuela
le traité avec la russie qui avait mis
un terme à la course à l'armement a été
complètement déchiré les relations entre
la chine se sont également beaucoup
dégradée on ne considère donc pas que
donald trump est véritablement un
faiseur de paix comme beaucoup de
soutiens l'espérer cela a je pense
beaucoup à voir avec la faune faction ii
makoun au sein de la cia et d'autres
partisans à israël par exemple partie du
coude
il ya donc des influences également
comme jared kushner au sein des états
unis qui ont poussé à une sorte d'
interventionnisme à l'étranger que
donald trump n'a pas pu être aussi
isolationniste que ses soutiens
l'espérer
où il se présente comme un président de
l'ordre de la loi pour restaurer la paix
aux états unis et maintenant il essaye
de restaurer son image à l'international
afin de se présenter effectivement comme
un faiseur de paix dans le monde
alors qu'au cours des quatre dernières
années ce n'est plutôt pas le cas alors
par ailleurs beaucoup pointent du doigt
la mauvaise gestion de la crise du
corona virus par donald trump le fait
qu'il ait minimisé le virus mais aussi
son climato scepticisme alors dans un
contexte de campagne électorale cette
signature peut-elle faire oublier les
dossiers au réputé moins glorieux du
président américain
le climato-scepticisme est très présent
aux états unis beaucoup de propriétaires
d'entreprises pensent que les
écologistes
en fait les empêche de produire et de
gagner des bénéfices notamment par
exemple cela est vrai au sein de
l'industrie de l'hydro fracturation et
beaucoup de grandes compagnies
pétrolières sont également contre tout
ce qui se rapporte à l'écologie et
donald trump et bénéficient de ce
soutien sur plusieurs plans s'agissant
de sa gestion du coronavirus c'est sans
doute le point de critique le plus fort
contre donald trump
mais il n'est pas certain que cela va
lui permettre va permettre à son rival
joe barton de remporter les états qui
sont vraiment dans la balance les
élections repose sur des états qui ne
sont ni traditionnellement républicain
et démocrate c'est eux qui déterminent
l'élection et on ne sait par six
les critiques concernant la gestion du
coronavirus vont permettre de changer la
donne dans ces états alors pour revenir
sur le fond de ces accords de
normalisation la vision pour la paix
présentée en début d'année par donald
trump qui visait à mettre fin une fois
pour toutes au conflit
israélo-palestinien est ce qu'on s'en
éloigne
cette proposition d'accord a été rejeté
par les palestiniens
il me considérait sa qu'il s'agissait
d'un plan valide pour la paix le plan
aurait aimé à une grande partie de la
cisjordanie tomber dans l'escarcelle
israélienne et il n'y aurait plus que
des enclaves palestiniennes israël
aurait tu as une opa sur les forces
armées et beaucoup de palestiniens et
est outragé par à la simple proposition
un tel plan mais effectivement cela a
donné beaucoup il n'aura très très
positive autour de 2 1 30 euro parti du
likoud et en israël c'est ce que
souhaitait de mettre un peu beaucoup
d'acteurs considérer que de quatre ans
c'était peut-être antisémite sa
politique d'accès populiste avait rendu
beaucoup de citoyens juifs et de
personnes juifs aux états unis créé un
très inquiète
mais là ils renforcent l'idée qui n'est
pas fâché ce qui n'est pas en faveur de
la suprématie blanche qu'il soutient
israël
je pense que la majorité des
fai américains auraient tendance à
vouloir voter démocrate mais à cette
alliance entre donald trump et israël
soleil changer la donne
après une audience avec son ego avec
d'autres instances avec le partizan
netanyahu afin de renforcer sa position
à la proche des élections
alors pour conclure on sait aussi que
l'armée américaine se désengage
progressivement de l'irak et de
l'afghanistan
du côté des émirats arabes unis ces
accords de normalisation sutil aussi un
moyen de se mettre sous la protection
américaine notamment en face à l'iran et
l'arabie saoudite devrait pas proposer
des forces armées dans la région contre
l'iran cette femme de colorisation
vraiment au coeur de la politique
étrangère de donald trump
il souhaite que les tensions soient
renforcés entre les autres pays de la
région et les rangs afin de renforcer le
lien entre les pays et sur le contrôle
s'agissant du retrait de trucs en iran
en afghanistan à en syrie en train
effectivement de vous parler de retrait
sans que cela se concrétise forcément
toujours complexe industriel aux
militaires et aux etats unis ue est très
puissant et différentes factions
différents courants sein de la maison
blanche paul différentes choses comme la
région
l'annonciation et des éléments de
l'administration trump souhaiterait
retirer les troupes et d'autres veulent
personnellement qu'elle soit maintenue
donc il y à différentes factions
différentes approches et tonate rock
lui veut surtout vendre des armes dans
la région l'arabie saoudite les émirats
arabes unis qui sont des années les
états unis sont des clients potentiels
s'agissant de la présence de tous est un
point sensible pour l'administration
américaine
merci beaucoup caleb maupin je rappelle
que vous êtes correspondant de rtl aux
états unis